[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau 7,8 journal nous sommes le
mercredi 30 novembre voici les titres de
l'actualité locale transports économie
déplacement urbanisme à quoi va
ressembler l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines dans quelques années
les élus de l'agglomération travaille
sur le projet de territoire et présentée
hier soir les premières grandes lignes
de ce projet lui aussi est en cours de
construction le nouveau centre
commercial open sky à plaisir les
travaux ont débuté pour accueillir les
nouveaux magasins en 2010 9 à guyancourt
une conférence débat autour des migrants
étaient organisées hier soir plusieurs
intervenants ont échangé leurs points de
vue pour tenter de briser un notamment
les idées reçues sur l'accueil des
migrants en france et dans les yvelines
non on ouvre ce journal avec la contre
attaque des élus franciliens 168 maires
d'île de france s'oppose dans une lettre
adressée à la maire de paris anne
hidalgo à la fermeture des voies sur
berge rive droite ils associés ils
s'associent dans leurs démarches à la
présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse qui a déposé un recours
devant le tribunal administratif contre
cette décision récemment dans les
yvelines plusieurs élus ont signé la
lettre notamment les maires de maurepas
plaisir de chiner de vélizy ou encore
d'elancourt il évoque notamment le
blocage général de la circulation à
paris et dénonce une indifférence à
l'égard des habitants de la petite et de
la grande couronne
écoutez à ce propos jean michel fourgous
le maire les républicains à d'elancourt
est évident que ça concerne les
parisiens faire mais ça concerne aussi
des gens qui vit qui organise des rendez
vous c'est une étude un site
international de rencontres les gens
arrivent au bourget ou à orly
inutile de vous dire que ça augmente de
30 à 50% comme le le temps de transport
quand il avait commencé la première zone
de paralysie
ça avait déjà été déjà très dur en
défense et une deuxième c'est vrai que
ça fait beaucoup
elle rallie miquel et d'aidés d'état
vérité qu'elle parle vrai mais qu'elle
dise pas qu'il n'y a pas d'augmentation
des embouteillages ou bien du tout bien
sûr de la bdd des délais de pour
traverser pas rien je vous le disais en
titre michelle logis et président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et joséphine coleman ce berger
première vice présidente de
l'agglomération ont présenté hier soir
le projet de territoire au théâtre de
saint quentin
un projet qui s'étalera sur 30 ans et
qui a pour but d'améliorer la vie des
habitants dans de multiples domaines
transport logement développement
économique
un parent au portage d'haussmann
vendeurs d et patrick jacques de dixmude
ils étaient plus de 350 spectateurs au
théâtre de 50 ans une ville pour la
soirée de lancement du projet de
territoire
le but améliorer la vie des saint
quentinois un projet auquel les
habitants pourront participer
je pense qu'on sera plutôt en
information directe avec des ateliers
des tables rondes pourquoi pas des
séminaires des rencontres véritablement
en lien direct avec la population et
avec les partenaires
moi je serais ravi de rencontrer les
entreprises et puis aussi l'université
et pourquoi pas les associations tout ça
aussi en lien et en partenariat avec le
codes skis le projet de territoire a
pour objectif d'améliorer les transports
les logements la circulation ou encore
le bien-être des saint quentinois
pour y arriver les douze communes de
l'agglomération doivent travailler
ensemble
nous étions sept avants pas forcément
aussi avec les mêmes appartenance
politique
en tout cas je crois que ce qui est bien
ensuite c'est que justement savez c'est
la somme de ces différences qui font que
ensuite on peut bâtir quelque chose de
tout à fait cohérent
l'événement s'est déroulé en présence de
pierre bédier le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines
il salue l'initiative nous sommes-nous
très favorable à ce projet de territoire
parce que saint quentin c'est une
formidable réussite sur les 50 dernières
années
c'est incontestable c'est sans doute les
experts le disent les observateurs la
ville nouvelle la plus réussie de toutes
les villes nouvelles mais elles
correspondent à un modèle d'autrefois
le modèle d'autrefois qui était le
modèle de l'exode rural où il fallait
organiser la ville désormais la ville
elle est à peu prêt à organiser mais
surtout la ville est en compétition et
les deux métropoles et elle est en
compétition avec les autres métropoles
unis avec le projet de territoire saint
quentin en yvelines prépare son avenir
durant l'année plusieurs réunions seront
organisées dans les communes
saint-quentinoise si vous souhaitez
donner votre avis sur le sujet rendez
vous sur le site de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines direction
plaisir à présent où les travaux sur la
galerie des tableaux ont débuté la
structure va être totalement détruite
pour devenir open sky un centre
commercial de 38 mille mètres carrés les
responsables planché également sur les
futurs magasins à présent dans
l'établissement
elle les précisions avec michael et demi
d'euros la galerie des sablons situé à
plaisir est en plein chantier la
structure est en train de subir un
profond lifting pour devenir le centre
baptisé open sky une structure de 38
mille mètres carrés avec une quarantaine
de magasins des restaurants et un
multiplexe d'une dizaine de salles pour
opérer cette mue spectaculaire tout sera
démoli pour être reconstruit
ça fait longtemps que cet ensemble
commercial qui est comme on dit dans son
jus c'est à dire qui date des années 80
et est je dirais
obsolète donc le projet de centres tels
que gianni ranallo l'architecte l'a
dessinée va d'un seul coup amener de la
modernité de l' architecture dans cette
partie de la zone qui en avaient besoin
en parallèle des travaux les
responsables s'activent pour attirer des
enseignes
les dirigeants ont annoncé la semaine
dernière la venue de la marque irlandais
ce prix marque la structure permettra
d'attirer une clientèle jeune la marque
a été créée en 1969 et ne compte que
neuf magasins en france
ce sera certainement la plus grande
surface du futur centre et ça va être
clairement pour nous une locomotive
très importante par les marques est une
enseigne qui est relativement nouvelle
en france mais qui s'implantent
rapidement et qui se développe beaucoup
dans pour nous c'est bien sûr un atout
pour nous et pour open sky c'est bien
sûr un atout important pour faire son
shopping dans cette boutique il faudrait
être patient
l'inauguration est programmée pour le
1er semestre 2010 9 à guyancourt se
tenait hier soir une conférence débat
autour de l'accueil des migrants co
organisée par le secours catholique
cette réunion a rassemblé plusieurs
acteurs locaux du dossier et notamment
etienne pinte ancien député maire de
versailles
reportage les migrants sont ils une
chance sont ils un défi pendant près de
deux heures les intervenants ont débattu
sur ces problématiques dans l'espace
paroissiale du cap saint jacques près de
70 personnes étaient présentes pour
écouter notamment le témoignage d'une
migrants arrivés en france il ya
plusieurs mois
également présents pour l'occasion l'ex
député maire de versailles etienne pinte
l'actuel président du conseil national
des politiques de lutte contre la
pauvreté a rappelé le devoir historique
de la france face aux mouvements
migratoires actuelles la france pays des
droits de l'homme et des citoyens le
pays des libertés qui a toujours été un
tueur une image en quelque sorte
d'accueil de l'étranger de celui qui
réfugiés de celui qui est expulsé de
celui qui est en souffrance eh bien nous
devons répondre à cette tradition et
nous avons les moyens
le pays est l'un des plus riches du
monde 5e ou 6e devancé en termes de
chiffres par l'allemagne la suède
l'italie ou encore la grèce est la
france est loin d'être le pays européen
le plus accueillant pour les migrants
pourtant les crispations sont nombreuses
sur le sujet en témoigne par exemple la
récente polémique sur l'accueil d'une
centaine de personnes à maurepas
il est quelque part un peu pratique le
migrant la crise c'est la faute du
migrant le système social en difficulté
c'est la faute du migrant le chômage
c'est la faute du migrant donc je pense
qu'il ya quelque part on l'a chargé de
tous les maux et aujourd'hui on a un
regard sur le
grand qui est extraordinairement chargé
on lui en veut d'une certaine manière
cette réunion autour des migrants se
tenait alors que selon les derniers
sondages près de six français sur dix
sont opposés à l'accueil de personnes
supplémentaires sur le sol hexagonal
vous l'avez sûrement aperçu si vous avez
l'habitude d'emprunter l'autoroute a12
le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et des hommes
habillés d'une structure de quatre ans
de 400 mètres carrés sur l'une de ses
façades pour accrocher des bâches
géantes en toile ces bâches permettront
de communiquer sur les événements
organisés par le vélodrome
écoutez à ce propos le directeur général
de vélo police hugues jarreau au micro
de michael et demi d'euros aujourd'hui
entre 120 et 150 mille automobile qui
passe à côté sur l'a12
donc l'idée c'est que les gens qui
viennent qui s'y passe à côté de ces
bâtiments puisse voir que celle des
autres nationale on mettra aussi de
temps en temps là la communication sur
l'événementiel donc ça permet aussi de
monter la visibilité pour les pour les
comment pour les promoteurs d'événements
sont certes et c'est intéressant
en sport toujours la section
cheerleaders de l'équipe de football
américain des templiers d'elancourt
prend l'accent russe victoria borodina
vient de rejoindre la structure pour
devenir coach adjointe
elle doit permettre à l'ensemble de la
section de s'améliorer sur les
techniques de portrait de portée nous
l'avons rencontré à l'occasion de son
premier entraînement un reportage une
nouvelle fois signé de miquel et demi
d'euros je m'appelle victoria boldin a
je suis russe victoria 27 ans la
nouvelle coach adjointe des cheerleaders
des templiers d'elancourt la russe
domicilié à montfort l'amaury depuis
quelques semaines a été embauchée suite
à une annonce postée par les dirigeants
sur facebook
la sportive espère transmettre son
expérience à ce club créé en 2012 ah
c'est une rigueur winehouse est in j'ai
commencé sur ledit de 18 ans j'ai fais
une équipe avec ma meilleure amie dans
notre université et ensuite j'ai intégré
des clubs de cheerleading
c'est vraiment une grande étape pour moi
d'avoir été une cheerleader en russie et
maintenant d'aider cette équipe de
france
la cheerleader travaillera en binôme
avec lorie fournier coach dans la
structure depuis trois ans je suis plus
spécialisé dans le tir dancing donc tout
ce qui va être chorégraphie et c est l
c'est vrai qu'elle a vraiment des bonnes
bases en cheerleading purée en termes de
stunt et c'est donc elle va elle va nous
apporter vraiment ce qui nous manquait
pour la section alors les stones en fait
ça va être les porter ça va être les
pyramides ce genre de choses donc un
conseil à des choses un peu gymnastique
pour sa première séance d'entraînement
ce lundi 28 novembre victoria dirigé dix
filles âgées de 15 à 24 ans elle nous a
un peu aidé à revoir les bases qui au
final était pas plus mal parce que on
avait pris quelques mauvaises habitudes
je suis flydoc au chant au jeu me fait
porter en fait et elle m'a appris plus
gai mais enfin comment bien gainer
comment bien se tenir sur
mais porter la nouvelle coach désormais
deux mois pour peaufiner les porter en
vue de la saison de football américain
qui débutera le 21 janvier prochain
domicile pour les templiers d'elancourt
on referme ce journal avec le vendée
globe 2016 la course est officiellement
terminée pour le versailles et tanguy de
lamotte le skipper d'initiative coeur
est rentrée ce lundi aux sables d'olonne
après avoir décidé d'abandonner au large
du cap-vert le 15 novembre dernier suite
à une avarie
plusieurs milliers de personnes se sont
rassemblées sur le port pour soutenir
l'yvelinois au total il aura passé à 23
jours en mer et aura permis de sauver
plus de 35 enfants atteints de problèmes
cardiaques
grâce à son sponsor fin de ce set 8
journal rendez vous demain pour une
nouvelle édition tous nos reportages
sont à retrouver en replay sur tv fil 78
points comme en attendant les programmes
se poursuivre sur notre antenne
[Musique]